à la possession ce qui sépare la rue
raymond mondon de l'océan c'est bien sûr
la route du littoral entre la ravine des
lataniers et la route de la montagne
elle s'étire bruyamment un raffut que
les riverains tentent d'oublier derrière
leur haie de bambous
oublie-t-il aussi le souvenir de raymond
mondon c'était raymond mondon ça ne dit
rien
un docker
vraiment pas du tout respire mais avec
ma faveur et un syndicaliste c'est le
membre de cette famille
dans le politique
mais un député c'était un élu aussi de
lieu de commune du pont raymond mondon
est né dans une modeste famille saint
louisienne en juillet 1917
brillant il réussit le concours d'entrée
au cours normal mixte de saint denis en
à 19 ans il obtient sa première
affectation à cilaos
puis il enseignera à piton saint-leu
grand bois saint louis avant de diriger
l'école de garçons du port en 1947
soucieux de l'éducation mais aussi des
sports et des loisirs des jeunes
il co fonde en 1949 la fédération des
oeuvres laïques
la folle raymond mondon est un actif
militant il créé la section locale du
syndicat national des instituteurs et
participe à l'union départementale
réunionnaise des syndicats et
fédérations aux côtés de raymond vergès
membres de la fédération réunionnaise du
parti communiste français
il va naturellement vers des fonctions
politiques conseiller municipal
conseiller général de saint pierre et en
janvier 1956 député de la réunion
un mandat qu'il perdra avec la chute de
la 4e république deux ans plus tard il
continuera toutefois son combat
notamment contre l' ordonnance dit debré
permettant la mutation d'office en
métropole de tout fonctionnaire
critiquant le pouvoir local
raymond restera toujours un enseignant à
partir de 1959 il dirige l'école des
camélias à saint denis
il y restera jusqu'à sa mort en 1972 le
6 août
raymond mondon tombe dans la cour de son
école foudroyé par une crise cardiaque
tous